depuis des mois ils travaillent comme
des fourmis à coups de pinceaux de
truelles et d'imagination ils refont une
beauté à leur ville 500 ans la vieille
dame ravagé par le teint par l'histoire
à cumuler les rides mais la capitale
cubaine est encore et toujours un
précieux diamant un formidable mélange
de styles dont la main reste intacte la
vallée de la vanne a la chance d'avoir
pu préserver son patrimoine
architectural et son image urbaine
d'antan al'inverse d'autres villes
d'amérique latine qui ont
malheureusement subi la perte d'une
bonne partie de leur patrimoine dans
leur centre historique à cause de la
pression immobilière
mais le paradoxe c'est que ce patrimoine
est en péril
voici le capitole sa restauration était
une oeuvre de grande envergure
monumentale et a duré plusieurs années
il a fallu faire appel à plusieurs
métiers d'art pour la réparation des
bronzes des plâtres des dorures des
menuiseries et de la coupole
je pense que c'est le projet phare est
emblématique de cette commémoration du
500e anniversaire de la fondation de la
havane
non c'est non seulement à cause de ce
que cela représente pour les cubains
mais aussi parce qu'on a dû effectuer
toutes les tâches nécessaires pour une
restauration
mais comment cacher la décadence des
résidences populaire à l'avant dont les
trouve partout y compris à deux pas du
capitole
ces communautés de locataires et de
squatteurs qui loge à l'étroit dans les
anciennes demeures de riches tellement
en mauvais état que certains menacent de
s'effondrer sans crier gare j'espère
qu'un jour ce bâtiment pourra retrouver
sa splendeur d'il y à 40 ans à mon
arrivée ici
cela me fait de la peine de voir la
façade un peu et même beaucoup
détériorées quand j'ai emménagé il y
avait beaucoup de lampes beaucoup de
choses et cela empire et à chaque fois
que d'autres personnes
aménagé dans le bâtiment et puis le mal
et comme ce fameux mal et comme malmené
depuis toujours par les raz-de-marée et
les ouragans
ce lieu leur peau cette promenade au
bord de la mer si attrayant pour le
touriste n'a jamais été abandonnée
complet la chose la plus navrante à la
havane aujourd'hui est le manque d'unité
chaque personne ne pense qu'à elle même
et ne se rend pas compte que la havane a
besoin de nous tous pour l'esthétique la
pauvreté
l'autre
reste que dans deux jours les
célébrations de l'anniversaire avec un
feu d'artifice d'exception vont
constituer comme un rayon de lumière sur
une ville qui doit faire face à une
situation économique de plus en plus
difficile en partie à cause du
renforcement d'un embargo vieux de
plusieurs décennies